[Musique]
la saison de ski bat son plein dans les
stations canadiennes mais cette année le
recrutement de saisonniers est un
casse-tête à skis saint-bruno station
populaire à une heure de montréal
plusieurs postes sont toujours à
pourvoir dans la restauration
mois en inde aux communes employés 13
environ à recruter pour une bonne
opération pour la cafétéria il mais
prend alors des questions mais dont
environ da et réponses et la
restauration mettons
sans quoi une quinzaine de personnes
pour complet opération séduction en
place désormais c'est l'employeur qui
doit convaincre les futurs employés
souvent des jeunes de 15 à 18 ans je
vais juste à montrer quelque chose tu as
quand même des bayles avantage qui
travaillent pour eux ce qui semble non
tu vas voir aussi la location
d'équipement gratuite dans ton cas si
jamais tu as fait du ski mais aussi de
nombreux tels moments par manque de
personnel l'unique bar de la station n'a
pas pu ouvrir pendant tout le mois de
décembre le manque d'employés donc il
faut que je fasse la caisse il faut que
je fasse même la cuisine il faut que je
fasse
elle planche et le recrutement pour
d'autres postes essentiels à la station
comme enneigeurs a été priorisé des
postes difficiles à combler car la
pandémie a changé la donne il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui ont décidé de
changer de vie changer leur façon de
faire les gens ne veulent plus
travailler 40 heures par semaine il nous
donne des 15 20 30 heures de
disponibilité donc dans le passé par
exemple à préposé aux remontées
mécaniques aujourd'hui ça nous en prend
2,3 pour pouvoir faire le même travail
tous les secteurs sont touchés par la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre au canada plus
de 900 12000 postes sont vacants c'est
près de deux fois plus qu'en 2019 le
québec est la province la plus affectée
64 % des pme peinent à recruter elles
doivent trouver de nouvelles façons
d'attirer les candidats et surtout les
garder
des sacs cadeaux de bienvenue pour les
nouveaux salariés
c'est le but ultime c'est vraiment des
crises
mais aussi deux maisons mises à
disposition gratuitement pour les
stagiaires et à moindre coût pour les
employés d'évolution entreprises en
sécurité informatique mise sur la
qualité de vie au travail pour séduire
les salariés s'il ya pas de culture dans
un entreprise les gens sont pas attachés
donc il devient plus volatiles
deviennent plus volatile a quitté
l'organisation ça vient rapidement
rentable d'investir
700 dollars par mois par employé pour
éviter justement l'effritement de la
main d'oeuvre s'assurer que mon regard
des gens actifs dans l'entreprise mais
heureux sur tout autre secteur en crise
la santé de nombreux hôpitaux doivent
fermer des lits parfois même des
services entiers par manque de personnel
vraiment cardiaque qui devrait avoir ici
hein
avec un patient coucher tout comme le
lit voisin ou ici aussi l'on devrait
avoir un patient couché dans le lit par
manque de main d'oeuvre malheureusement
on doit si vous les déplacez le
personnel qui s'occupait de ses deux
villas ailleurs sur l'unité ça m'affecte
pas ce que c'est pas comme ça ça devrait
fonctionner un problème de sous-effectif
aggravée par la cinquième vague ou
micron ça va être encore très précaire
de soir c'est ça on va tous obligés de
faire du temps supplémentaire
si on manque de main d'oeuvre on peut
pas demain et primes et des infirmières
puissent fabriquer des préposés avec
avec des lego danser des choses qui
doivent être mis en place sur des années
on a vu qu'il y avait un taux de
retraite s'est accélérée versus le tout
formation donc c'est des choses qu'on
n'avait pas si vous voulez prévu jusqu'à
un certain point mais c'est vrai que
pour les gens sur le terrain on a hâte
de tourner la page le gouvernement
québécois a annoncé mi janvier une
enveloppe de 500 millions de dollars de
primes de congés payés et d'heures
supplémentaires doublement rémunérés
pour les travailleurs de la santé